et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
donc julien de normandie bonjour
monsieur le ministre merci beaucoup
d'être avec nos mines et l'agriculture
et de l'alimentation on est ensemble
pendant plus de 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale pour présentée par
julien lécuyer qui dirige le bureau
parisien de la voix du nord bonjour
bonjour yanbu jean monsieur ministre on
va évidemment parler de vos dossiers ils
sont nombreux julien normandie mais
d'abord cette intervention des manuels
macron deux heures hier soir sur tf1 et
lci on a eu le bilan des îles mea culpa
on a eu une esquisse d'un futur
programme aussi est-ce que vous admettez
que hier soir pendant deux heures on a
écouté le futur candidat à la
présidentielle plus que le premier but
plutôt que le président de la république
moi je veux d'abord je crois que c'était
un exercice très intéressant très utile
et j'ai été on en parle est un instant
très surpris par le nombre de messages
que j'ai pu recevoir
disant tout simplement
n'y a pas à dire on a quand même un
président de la république est au dessus
du lot et j'ai été très surpris parce
que j'ai reçus vraiment
de
tout horizon mais vraiment de tout
horizons de toutes sensibilités
politiques et je crois que c'est tout à
fait juste
je ne vois pas qui aujourd'hui à sa
carrure qui est à cette énergie qui a
cette volonté d'action qui a eu
également
7,7 humilité hier dans 10 à sa carrure
de reprendre pour autant interview et je
voudrais je voudrais juste terminée sur
un point et on parlera de des mois après
je pense qu'il y ait au delà de du
contenu de l'émission je pense également
que a été mise en avant le courage le
courage des manuels macron le courage ne
pas fermer les écoles et les réouvrir le
courage de prendre des décisions
incroyablement difficile dans une
période qui l'était tout autant et je ne
sais pas objectivement sincèrement dans
quel état serait la france aujourd'hui
au moment où on se parle si emmanuel
macron n'avait pas eu le courage
d'affronter la crise comme il l'a fait
alors on allait donc cette émission sur
moi et c'est très importante pour
pouvoir
expliquer aussi revenir sur le passé la
jeunesse des décisions le pourquoi du
comment la vision qui est la sienne et
je crois que cet égard c'était c'était
fort utile
une raison de faire de cake mea culpa il
en est il en a fait un sûr c'est sur ces
formules blessantes il était temps
qu'ils qui revoit son image auprès des
français
en tout état de cause il le dit très
bien et à très juste titre au moment où
il est élu en 2017 il est peu connu des
français il est tout jeune politique il
ça fait que quelques années qu'il est
ministre de l'économie avant son entrée
est donc libre il peu connu des français
je pense que c'est très important que
cette proximité entreprises au nom de la
république et les français puissent se
faire puissent être explicité puisse
être comprise et hier il a mis en avant
avec beaucoup d'humilité les erreurs
qu'il a pu faire que ce soit dans des
phrases où que ce soit dans des actions
de tous les jours où on en connaît tous
des erreurs je pense que c'est important
de les reconnaître c'est aussi ça de
faire de la politique différemment
jamais se dire que on est pétri de
convictions qui fait qu on aurait
toujours
j'ai changé j'ai changé hier emmanuel
macron sais j'ai appris j'ai appris
c'est pas vraiment différent nicolas
sarkozy par exemple
si si manuel macro nicolas sarkozy s'en
différencie ce je vous le confirme
hier on a on a un président de la
république qui a mêlé une hauteur de vue
en tout point exceptionnelle singulair
le courage d'un d'un dirigeant d'un chef
d'état les français ils veulent un chef
d'état quelqu'un cap en capacité de
décider et en capacité de tenir la barre
et en même temps quelqu'un de
profondément humain
s'adressant aux français en leur disant
toute l'affection qu'il a pour eux toute
la volonté qu'il a à la fois de changer
la france est d'accompagner des français
et je crois qui plus est vous savez
pendant longtemps nous est demandé mais
c'est quoi en fait la ligne politique
voulue par président de la république le
fameux libéré protéger mes lire le
problème du en même temps ce fameux
libéré protéger je croyais qu'on ait eu
une belle explication de ce qu'est le
libérer protégé qui a pris aussi toute
sa substance avec le libérer les
énergies l'économie la possibilité qu'on
a eu deux aujourd'hui avoir un taux de
chômage jamais vu dans notre pays et en
même temps le protéger dans les moments
durs ne jamais laisser tomber quiconque
alors même si là il a eu beaucoup évoqué
son bilan il a quand même laissé
transparaître certaines choses notamment
sur la crise sanitaire et sur la
vaccination obligatoire
alors il le dit pas comme ça mais il dit
quand même qu'il ya une possibilité pour
qu'on en vienne à la comaga pour la
diphtérie et le tétanos vers une
vaccination une vaccination obligatoire
on y va tout droit selon vous
objectivement je au
mois en tant que ministre gris cultures
de l'alimentation je vais pas me
prononcer sur quel est le bon chemin
vaccinale ou quelles sont les prochaines
décisions sanitaire vous l'avez reçu
comme comme ça comme non gelée reçues
comme un message très clair c'est la
seule solution c'est la vaccination
à n'en pas douter et je crois d'ailleurs
que ir on a pu voir cette cohérence dans
l'ensemble des décisions qu'on a prises
et j'insiste dessus sur cette cohérence
parce que on peut parler aussi des
oppositions vous receviez une sénatrice
à un instant dans ce cas précis beaucoup
mais je sur la vaccination mais moi il
ya quelque chose qui m'a profondément
choqué mais alors vraiment profondément
choqué et dont on a très peu parlé avez
vous vu cette proposition de valérie
pécresse consistant à dire il faut
absolument rendre gratuit tous les tests
avant noël
ça fait deux fois trois fois qu'elle
fait cette proposition est ce qu'on se
rend compte de la chose aujourd'hui les
tests sont gratuits pour toute personne
vaccinée toute personne vaccinée toute
personne avec une ordonnance où tous les
jeunes d'hier on rend les tests gratuits
est en fait de dire à tous ceux qui ne
sont pas vaccinés vous inquiétez pas on
va vous rendre les tests gratuits elle
est où la cohérence c'est hier le
message de noël ce soit aussi un moyen
pour les jours les non vaccinés
évidemment la première des priorités
c'est quand même que les gens ne
m'aiment non vaccinés nalpas vraie mine
contaminer d'autres idées où est la
cohérence politique quand aujourd'hui on
sait tous mais tout ce que la seule arme
dont on dispose c'est le vaccin allez
expliquer à nos concitoyens quelles que
soient les raisons en fait on va lâcher
prise sur ce vaccin en ouvrant d'autres
possibilités et à mes yeux totalement
irresponsable et hier sur la politique
sanitaire pour répondre à votre question
moi j'ai vu cette cohérence cette
cohérence d'une politique sanitaire
tourné vers la vaccination vers la
protection et permettant de prendre
aussi ces mesures courageuses comme
celle sur des écoles dernier mot sur la
crise sanitaire puisqu'on voit la
cinquième vague est très forte il ya une
inquiétude sur le vario omicron dans les
prochaines semaines ya le salon avec une
chose qu'on doit se tenir fin février
début mars est ce qu'il pourra se tenir
de manière au moment où je vous parle on
fait tout pour au moment où je vous
parle oui après je obligé
au moment au moment où je vous parle on
fait tout pour au moment où je vous
parle oui après nous sommes le 16
décembre il seulement d'agriculture et
fin février ce qui est sûr c'est plus on
aura vacciner plus on aura on se sera
collectivement battu contre ce virus ou
ces variants plus la chance qu'on aura
de pouvoir tenir le salon de
l'agriculture mais plus globalement de
pouvoir retrouver une vie la plus
normale possible sera forte
très compliqué parce que la limite pour
tenir ces salles on allait elle est en
réalité déjà passé après vous avez
différentes étapes et vous avez d'autres
étapes
au mois de janvier puis defacto début
février avec l'installation mais encore
une fois au moment où je vous parle oui
à l'évidence c'est une grande fête à la
fois pour le monde agricole mais pour
les français c'est la première ferme de
france donc on va tout faire pour
mais évidemment je suis obligé de vous
dire au moment où je vous parle et
deuxièmement redire que plus nous
arriverons à nous faire vacciner et puis
nous arrivons à nous protéger et à
lutter collégialement contre cette
épidémie plus la chance de se retrouver
lors de ce salon de l'agriculture ou à
d'autres moments sera forte on parlait
de encore une fois de l'intervention
présidentielle beaucoup ont critiqué en
ce ce qu'ils ont appelé un braquage mais
médiatique dans un président qui est
candidat putatif mais néanmoins
quasiment à virer est ce que vous
comprenez les
l'opposition qui réclame que ce temps de
parole soit décompté au titre du
président candidat
c'est une forme de faire de la polémique
partout et surtout jamais de regarder ce
que il avait pu faire avant enfin je
crois plusieurs l'ont mis en avant
certains de vos collègues expliquant les
prises de parole à la fois du président
sarkozy mais même du président
mitterrand en son temps le cas d'un vol
avaient été décomptés est-ce que ce soit
en avril deuxièmement sur le temps de
parole les règles elles sont très
claires il s'avère que c'est pas le
gouvernement que les établis c'est le
csa a donc le temps de parole le csa
établit les règles c'est ça fait
respecter les règles et je ne suis
personne pour dire ce que doit faire le
csa c'est le csa qui fait c'est quand
même c'est quand même au demeurant très
bien que dans une république il ya un
conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel qui a
ses règles qui sont fixés et qui se
charge de les faire appliquer
valérie pécresse sur sa proposition de
supprimer près de 200000 postes de
fonctionnaires il a dit il faut du
sérieux il faut être précis il a attaqué
le rigorisme budgétaire aussi de valérie
pécresse il a parlé de faire front et à
elle vous inquiète tant que ça la
candidate de la droite
moi je vous savez je suis
pas de ceux qui
ont tourner leurs regards regard pardon
vers les oppositions je suis surtout de
ceux qui
a le regard fixé aujourd'hui sur
qu'est-ce qui est ce qu'on doit faire
encore dans les 4 mois utiles après je
souhaite profondément que le président
la république se représente et qu'est ce
qu'on doit faire pour ensuite conduire
le pays jusqu'à 2030 et donc je suis
vraiment de ce qui a la conviction et
c'est d'ailleurs aussi c'est ce qu'on
fait depuis 2010 est de tourner le
regard vers le devant plutôt que sur les
côtés avec
les oppositions maintenant une fois que
j'ai dit ça
la question hier poser est en réalité
assez saine et je pense que c'est
important que tous les français le
sachent
on veut supprimer des postes on va faire
des coupes budgétaires pas simplement
dans les
îles ça veut rien dire ça veut rien dire
ou donc dans quel secteur d'activité est
pourquoi je dis ça parce que vous savez
en france ont comme on dit chat échaudé
craint l'eau froide quand valérie
pécresse était ministre du budget c'est
le même moment où il ya douze mille
fonctionnaires de police de moins au
même moment au même moment c'est au même
moment où avant elle était ministre de
la recherche et des universités
on n'ouvre pas le numerus clausus il
pouvait être ouvert à cette époque il
n'a pas été ouvert elle en avait le
besoin normandie vous au même moment où
la tva
donc
hier ce qui parle et d'imprécisions et
pourtant politique c'est là aussi
n'a pas vraiment défini ce qui est ce
qu'ils comptaient faire part par la
suite et c est ce que c'est pas une
encore une fois une difficulté d'arriver
devant les devants les français
d'exposer qui va faire qui va qu'il veut
faire une réforme des retraites l'a
composé de trois régimes et supprimer
les régimes les quarante deux régimes
spéciaux dire qui va moderniser la vie
pu administrer son public y compris il
le dit hein il compris peut-être en
supprimant des postes mais il n'en fait
pas l'alpha et l'oméga juste titre
peut-être mais en fait il reste deux
vous exposez plus clairement c'est sûr
c'est sur ces deux exemples je peux pas
vous laisser dire qu'à raison de la
réforme des retraites la réforme des
retraites a été voté une première fois
l'assemblée nationale d'ailleurs en
utilisant le 49-3 qu'est ce que dit le
président de la république mais cette
réforme la rivière comme d'ailleurs
quelques semaines avant il dit il faut
absolument faire la réforme des
retraites il a expliqué pourquoi il
n'avait pas pu la faire il ya un an il
deale toujours
il dit cette réforme des retraites en
revanche faudra la faire différemment de
celle qui avait été adoptée à mes
différents qui me met il dit ce débat
devra être portée qui dans la campagne
présidentielle ou qui après bon mais on
ne peut pas dire que la vision de la
réforme des retraites du président
macron n'est pas connue dans ses
modalités elle doit être évidemment
précisé mais l on se pose c'est celle
modalités qui sont importantes d'accord
mais il il n'est pas annoncé le déroulé
de toute une réforme des retraites sa
vision en disant il faut faire en sorte
qu'on puisse arrêter les régimes
spéciaux rendre le système plus juste
faire en sorte que les pensions de
retraite puisse être revalorisé
des mois
une injure de personnes de la preuve
quand la fonction publique la fonction
publique excusez moi la fonction
publique et je salue son travail ça fait
des mois et des mois et des mois camilli
de montchanin a mise en oeuvre une
réforme profonde de la fonction publique
et je crois que là aussi elles permises
et elle n'est pas terminée cette
expliquer mais le chemin il est très
clair on va s'atteler au reste de
l'actualité à vos dossiers sont nombreux
je viens de normandie c'est un certain
mr écologistes ont banni le foie gras
réception officielle de leur mairie
qu'est ce que vous pensez bien mais je
pense que
vous savez j'avais à mes prédécesseurs
qui disait une gare pisani que j'admire
beaucoup qui disait le drame en
politique c'est de sombrer dans le
détail il oublier l'essentiel je pense
qu'une politique une vision politique
qui repose sur ici la suppression des
sapins ou la la suppression du foie l'a
parfois l'arrêt du tour de france est un
très bon exemple de ce que edgar pisani
voulait dire on sombre dans le détail ce
n'est pas une vision politique que de
dire moi mon projet de supprimer de foie
gras moi mon projet c'est supprimer des
sapins
qui prisaient
personnellement comme beaucoup de
français
j'ai la chance d'avoir un sapin chez moi
et je suis très content de pouvoir en
profiter avec mes quatre enfants je
compte bien manger du foie gras à noël
escalettes est
ce que le foie gras est une partie de
notre identité oui oui et est-ce qu'on
peut être
des territoires mais où est ce qu'il
s'arrête le bien-être animal vous savez
quand vous allez dans un bois vous avez
vous allez c'est quoi l'étape d'après
vous allez dans un abattoir on va dire
et c'est d'ailleurs très intéressant
votre question parce que je vais vous
faire un scoop pour manger de la viande
faut tuer un animal
ça fait la fin de l'animal elle est
potentiellement assez tragique et vous
voyez le débat qu'on a aujourd'hui dans
la société même si le débat le débat sur
le gave à 10 soit pas sur le banc ce que
je veux dire par là c'est que
aujourd'hui on tourne dans une société
où au titre du bien-être animal ou
d'autres on va en arriver à se dire eh
bien demain on arrête le foie gras et
puis l'étape d'après ces on va arrêter
trop gras c'est d'ailleurs la question
qui a été posée est ce qu'il faut a
priori ce qu'il faut améliorer des
pratiques à l'évidence oui et c est ce
qu ont investi dans les élevages à
l'évidence oui est ce qu'on prend des
mesures de protection de sanitaires
comme on fait d'ailleurs non ce moment à
cause de l'influencé à l'avenir à
l'évidence oui mais est-ce que le débat
se résume en disant au titre du
bien-être animal on va arrêter beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de nos traditions nos
traditions du territoire et à la fin
vous remettre en cause y compris des
éléments élémentaire de ce qui fait
notre composition de femmes et d'hommes
c'est à dire c'est y compris manger de
la viande ça moi je m'inscris totalement
en faux et ça ça devient parfois sur la
place publique je sais pas si vous avez
vu aujourd'hui il ya tout un débat en
disant est il possible de faire de la
viande de synthèse son appel de la
viande cellulaire donc c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui dans notre société on est en
train de créer du gigot d'agneau sans
agneau du blanc de poulet sans poulet
pourquoi parce qu'on se dit ben en fait
l'acte de tuer l'animal n'est plus
acceptable à moi en tant qu'homme ou en
tant que femme moi je pense à poser un
vrai question d'anthropologie avoir une
vraie question est donc là je pense
qu'il faut assumer qu'on a d'être à dix
on est un peu paumé
voile sur la table de monsieur le
ministre exactement à côté d'un beau
sapin
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on a sept cas dans des
élevages
principalement dans le nord de notre
pays
mais on a de linkfluence aviaire qui est
à peu près partout autour de nous en
belgique en italie beaucoup en allemagne
et donc on est on est on est on a on a
cette vigilance extrême est vraiment
extrême qui nous a conduit d'ailleurs à
prendre des décisions très dures pour
nos éleveurs et je voudrais vraiment les
saluer parce que on a mis des mesures de
protection pour éviter ou retarder au
maximum l'arrivée de ce virus est à voir
à éviter des décisions que l'année
dernière à la même époque j'étais déjà
en train de prendre c'est à dire au père
et l'abattage de centaines de milliers
puis 2 millions de volailles
de palmipèdes doute gallinacés et donc
on a pris des mesures de protection très
dur mais ces mesures de protection
n'empêche jamais le risque zéro et donc
on a une vigilance totale là-dessus
jordi le virus une ligne fluide ça vire
et n'empêchent en rien mais en rien de
manger du foie gras de manger des oeufs
il revient de manger
ses belles volailles ça n'est pas
transmissible par par les aliments donc
aucun problème là dessus alors autre
question qui concerne les manger du foie
gras on avait compris que quand on est
là votre question qui concerne la
légalisation en l'occurrence et les
poules en cage après deux ans d'attentes
le décret interdisant toutes nouvelles
installations d'élevage de poules en
cage a été publié en deux ans deux ans
quatre ans alors pardon de vous couper
pourquoi parce qu'en fait on a mis en
place c'était la question que j'arrive
au gouvernement d mais c'est justement
parce qu'il a fallu quand même attendre
la saisine du conseil d'état par une
association de défense des animaux
d'élevage
pourquoi en fait on l'a fait à titre
on appelle ça les circulaires on a on a
donné le cadre et le conseil d'état a
dit il ne faut pas que ce soit juste un
cadre donné il faut que c'est une valeur
réglementaire avec un texte
réglementaire nous on est venu préciser
par un texte réglementaire mais l'esprit
de la loi qui précédait donc ce texte
réglementaire est bien appliquée depuis
déjà deux ans et d'ailleurs c'est très
intéressant parce que c'est quoi en gros
il ya quelques années dans la loi et
galim la première a été décidé de faire
en sorte que tout nouveau bâtiment
d'élevage puisse avoir ses accès en
plein air une demande du citoyen très
légitime
mais ce qui est très intéressant de voir
c'est aujourd'hui le nombre de
poulaillers de plein air qui fait
l'objet de recours
parce que tous autour de la table en
tant que citoyen on dit là nous on veut
bien et on préfère que les poules elles
soient dehors que les cochons ils soient
dehors oui
message allez disons que c'est assez
facile quand ici les studios sont on all
au jardin du luxembourg
la probabilité que dans le jardin du
luxembourg vous ayez des milliers de des
milliers de porcs est somme toute assez
limité par contre quand vous êtes dans
d'autres territoires et que c'est à côté
de chez vous ben sont là vous avez
beaucoup de voisins qui posent leur
cours ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que on a une bonne intention de bonnes
intentions collégiale avec cette demande
citoyenne de dire mettons les poulets
poule dehors mettons les cochons d'or
mais il faut assurer dans l'est dans la
réalité c'est quand les agriculteurs les
éleveurs font leurs projets qu'est ce
qu'on voit recours sur recours sur
recours sadok les projets et c'est très
intéressant parce que voyez c'est cette
forme de cohabitation des contraires
dans laquelle on est tous plongés on en
a tous dans nos for intérieur des
cohabitations des contraires mais on y
est tous plongés et parfois il faut
arrêter du blanc ou du noir c'est
parfois très compliqué y compris dans
l'acceptation sociale comme sur la levée
galim puisque vous venez d'en parler la
loi galim 2 qui a donc été évoqués ont
voté on en est on en est ou de son
application aujourd'hui à ce que la
grande distribution joue en fin de jeu
alors ça va vous faire plaisir les
textes d'application sont déjà pris bah
ouais et quelques jolis rassurer j'étais
maudit le module aux modules haut
un ou deux qui sont en ce moment au
conseil d'état pour publication ensuite
on a ce matin même d'ailleurs le comité
de suivi des relations commerciales ou
ont réuni toute la grande distribution
tous les industriels et tout la monde de
la chaîne et galim 2 a changé la donne a
changé la nature des relations à
l'évidence maintenant on est dans une
situation où vous avez une telle
augmentation des prix de production une
telle augmentation qu'il faut que
l'effort consenti et par la grande
distribution et par les industriels
soit significative voire très
significatif les relations commerciales
c'est c'est une relation de tension mais
c'est surtout
une bataille entre les uns et les autres
c'est un rapport de force avec cette
fois ghanim 2 on a permis de réarmer le
monde agricole dans ce rapport de force
et donc on aura à nouveau cette réunion
ce matin pour mettre la pression dans le
pub et faire en sorte qu'elle soit
pleinement à cliquer c'est essentiel à
mes yeux parce que évidemment on peut
pas faire d'agriculture sans
agriculteurs ne pas pas avoir
d'agriculteurs s'ils sont pas rémunérés
ça me permet d'être de faire une
transition vers le recensement agricole
1 ce document assez ces normes qui
qu'ils paient pas assez vaste au wiki
qui permet de faire une sorte de deux
dessins assez précis du du paysage à
l'heure actuelle et
pourrait nous éclairer un peu parce que
c'est vrai que selon ce dernier
recensement il ya cent mille
exploitations supplémentaires qui ont
disparu en dix ans
je vous cite les chiffres vous les
connaissez par coeur mais il n'en reste
plus que 3 190 contre 490 en 2010 six
cent soixante trois mille en 2000 et ce
qui a pas un péril pour l'agriculture
française à bas il ya un enjeu qui
majeur mais je vais vous prêcher un
convaincu je veux dire je me bats je me
lève tous les matins
pour lutter contre cela ce que lutter
contre ce risque quelle est la plus
grande de nos souverainetés ça reste
quand même la capacité qu'on a de se
nourrir et de se nourrir avec nos
produits et avec nos produits de qualité
parce que c'est quand même fabuleux un
toutes les études à travers le monde
vante la qualité de l'agriculture
française tous et alors ce recensement
il dit quoi il dit effectivement qu'une
diminution du nombre d'exploitants
d'exploitation précisément et des
engrais sur l'attention il dit aussi des
choses très intéressantes il dit qu'on a
un modèle agricole qui reste
profondément attaché à taille humaine la
moyenne ces 69 ha mais c'est trois fois
moins qu'aux états unis je crois
exactement il dit aussi que on a des
exploitations agricoles tourné vers la
qualité et ce dernier recensement
montrent que plus d'un tiers des
exploitations l'exploitation pardon
produits des produits sous label très
intéressant et puis surtout quand on
rentre dans le détail ce qu'on voit et
c'était pour moi je ne savais pas quel
serait le résultat c'était pour moi un
des éléments que j'attendais avec eux le
plus d'anxiété si je puis dire c'est
qu'on voit en fait que la part des moins
de 40 ans n'a pas diminué
ce recensement le fait tous les dix ans
donc on a l'image 2010 2020 par rapport
à l'image 2000 le 1010 et on voit que la
part des 40 ans des moins de 40 ans n'a
pas diminué ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'en fait on a un secteur qui
reste attractif et d'ailleurs le nombre
d'installations de jeunes chaque année
reste à peu près stable et un
vieillissement j'ai eu les rasets
notamment résumé en revanche on voit un
vieillissement très important ce qui
fait que même si on a un secteur qui
reste attractif on n'est pas en capacité
au moment où je vous parle à répondre à
l'ensemble des départs à la retraite ce
qui veut dire que la politique on a
fondé sur l'installation des jeunes
d'abord la vision politique est la bonne
mais il faut amplifier amplifié amplifié
aujourd'hui on doit être à 14000
installations par an il faudrait passer
à 20 c'est ça merci beaucoup merci
julien de normandie notre invité ce
matin bonne fête avec du foie gras sur
la table on l'a compris merci d'avoir
été notre invité
[Musique]